I did 500 days without caffeine just to
see what happened I did a thousand days
without alcohol did you notice any
difference though from like six months
to a thousand days from alcohol get yeah
and that was mostly consistency of habit
there was no break if you think about
what a hangover is a hangover is
collecting to make yourself ill acutely
for 36 hours no I'm gonna throw my world
up for 36 hours and then caffeine the
reason for that was I just felt like I
didn't ever talk about being tired of
being awake what I did think about was I
have varying levels of caffeine
concentration in my blood like if you
listen to the language that people say
they don't say I'm tired they say I need
a coffee maybe if you wanted papering
over the cracks of your fatigue you'd
ask yourself the question why am I tied
at 11 30 a.m you're not supposed to be
tired at 11 30 a.m so you mask over the
fact that you're not sleeping enough
you're not prioritizing recovery you use
your phone until 11 pm at night every
single evening there's a coffee in you
before your adenosine system is even
active you're not hydrating properly
you're not taking any magnesium or
sodium or potassium